hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar chromatin immunoprecipitation
five steps to great results
I am Alexis Krause of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lavage
and brought to you by thermo Fisher
Scientific to learn more about our
sponsor
please visit www.disabilitydenials.com
for a session box located on the far
left your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speaker dr. Eliza small scientist three
protein biology antibodies and
immunoassays Thermo Fisher Scientific
dr. small has worked at Thermo Fisher
Scientific since 2015 she works in the
antibody and amino acids group and
focuses particularly on identifying new
epigenetic targets to develop antibodies
and antibody validation
prior to joining Thermo Fisher
Scientific Eliza earned her PhD at the
University of Chicago where she studied
the mechanism of regulating the
spliceosome by several pre mRNA splicing
factors Eliza did her postdoctoral work
at Northwestern University examining
nucleosome position at the single cell
level in East at the outcome of several
epigenetic mutations in hematological
malignancies
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr. small you may not
be
your presentation great thank you so
much Alexis for the introduction and
thank you everyone for joining this
webinar whether live or later on-demand
today I'm going to talk to you about the
ins and outs of tip or chromatin
immunoprecipitation as I was already
introduced my name is Eliza small I've
been with thermo Fisher for just over
three years where I work in the antibody
and immunoassays group focusing on new
product and development and validation
in epigenetic and signaling research
Tyra - that I was a postdoc at
Northwestern University I started my
postdoctoral training in nucleosome
positioning and Jonathan widows lab and
continued that work as well as examining
several epigenetic factors in John licks
lab I did my PhD at the University of
Chicago examining spliceosomes
and how they are regulated in the
Stanley lab so now on to talking about
tip or chromatin immunoprecipitation tip
is a technique for getting a snapshot or
picture of protein DNA interactions at a
given moment there are two main types of
chip which I will discuss in more detail
a bit bit but they are cross-linked tip
or X chip and native chip there's also a
number of variations of chip that have
been developed recently and those though
however will not be discussed in this
webinar
with this technique you can ask where
your parting of interest is and is not
in the genome at a single time point so
you can ask if your protein that you're
interested in is associating with
actively transcribed genes repressed
genes or is it in discrete regions in
the genome or spread out throughout the
genome further if you start beginning to
study gene regulatory elements you can
actually start to obtain a 3d picture
with this two-dimensional data
there's a number of things to consider
before starting the tip experiment first
is what do you know about the binding of
your protein of interest do you know
that it binds DNA directly or does it
bind DNA as part of a protein complex
and depending upon how large that
protein complex may depend on how you
want to set up your experiment also if
the protein binds the DNA directly how
stable is that binding is it rather
transient coming on and off the DNA
rather quickly or once it binds is quite
stable there other things to consider
are what are you interested in learning
about your protein do you know define
eight regions that your protein of
interest binds that you're interested in
investigating or are you interested in
understanding where your protein is on a
more genome-wide level also do you even
know regions where your protein is
generally expected to be bound and not
bound
another thing to think about before you
start your tip experiment are all the
reagents and equipment you need for tip
not surprisingly you need a place to
grow yourself you need water or heat
block for temperature can be controlled
you in most cases need a sonicator
you'll need access to a qPCR machine for
being able to analyze your DNA output
from your chip experiment and you will
need a lot of enzymes buffers beads
antibodies and other reagents to that
point often tip kits are considered a
great option as many of the reagents
required for your tip experiment are
included in the tip kit here I show on
the left a snapshot of a magnetic tip
kit offered by thermo scientific and you
can see there's a bunch of reagents that
are included in this kit beyond having a
number of the Regents they're all
optimized for chips
that being said you'll see throughout
the webinar that chip requires lots of
optimization for your cell type and what
your protein of interest is so although
these kits are optimized for chip you
still will need to do plenty of
optimization on your own for your
specific experiment I also want to
mention at this point that on the right
side there's featured projects so in
this case it's the three chip kits the
thermo scientific has to offer but
throughout this webinar I will often
have on the right side featured products
that I would recommend for your chip
experiments
so now let's begin in this webinar is
divided into five sections for tip
cross-linking and lysis where which is
where you stabilize complexes and
isolate nuclear fractions then the
chromatin fragmentation where if you
take that very long chromatin and
fragment it so that you can get optimal
resolution and efficient immuno
precipitation the immunoprecipitation
step is where you capture and isolate
your protein DNA complexes so this is
where you're pulling out your protein of
interest in finding out what to
ultimately find out what DNA it
associates with then the preparation of
DNA and finally the quantitation of DNA
which is really what your output for
your chip experiment is so let's get
started the first step is cross-linking
and lysis
question is do you need to crosslink
your tip experiment and that really
depends on how stable the interaction
you're studying is if it's not stable
such as a transcription factor or
another factor that you expect is coming
on and off your DNA rather quickly which
is many factors in the cell you really
do need to cross link is you need to
kind of freeze that protein to your DNA
so that you can later pull it down
alternatively you might be interested in
a very stable interaction and these very
stable interaction is something like a
histone modification where the
nucleosome is pretty tightly on the
chromatin and so you might you may not
need to require cross-linking at back
the question though is in your chip
experiment are you only interested in
these very specific stable interactions
and if that is the case so if you're
interested in say several histone
modifications and how they associate
with the genome the native chip our end
chip may be the way to go and the
benefit to doing native chip is that
cross-linking in itself does increase
your background so you've eliminated one
issue in a chip experiment however often
you're interested in not only that
histone modification but you're
interested also in some other factors
involved in one kind of overall chip
experiment so you might cross link a
bunch of cells and then divide them up
and do several immuno precipitations and
if you're interested in both stable and
unstable interactions you're going to
want to cross link so again it just
depends on what you're interested in if
it's necessary to cross link or not
now if you are cross-linking the
question is what is the right cross
linker first and foremost you're going
to want to use formaldehyde formaldehyde
is the most common cross linker and it
cross links protein and DNA interactions
although it does also cross link very
close proximity protein protein
interactions it's reversible which is
key because ultimately you want to
release the DNA from the protein now if
your protein of interested in is the
complex and does not directly bind to
the DNA you may need an additional cross
linker so at the bottom if you are
interested in of course the red or blue
proteins you would not need a cross
linker but if say you're interested in
that gray protein that's depicted as a
ball that's an alert or complex and
further away from the DNA you may need
an additional cross linker and dsg and
DSP are two such cross linkers that are
useful in this case
now I'm going to go through quickly the
kind of general workflow for
cross-linking in this example it's using
a million cells per mil but this is
something that can very much be scaled
up or down and people are doing lower
and lower amount numbers of cells and
having successful chips
once you dilute your cells in the media
to the appropriate concentration if you
need a protein protein cross linker
it'll be added at this stage after that
you'll fix the cells with formaldehyde
and incubate often for about 10 minutes
is an appropriate length but this is a
step that may need to be optimized for
your cell type after the incubation you
want to quench with glycine and this is
really essential as over cross-linking
can rate or cause problems down the road
in your chip experiments you do want to
quench incubate that quench and then
wash off that glycine and formaldehyde
with PBS and this stage is one of the
best stopping points in a chip
experiment it's the stage where you
cross-linked quenched and washed
yourself and these can be stored at
minus eighty of the cell pellets almost
for several years at least so it really
is a great place for stopping your tip
experiment if you don't want to continue
or if they you want to do some chromatin
IP that this stage but also save some
more cells later for doing another type
of experiment
next after cross-linking the cells or if
you have not if there was no need to
cross lengths of cells your cells would
often have been washed in PBS and stored
at minus 80 or continuing right on you
need to lyse the cells and racing the
cells there's multiple ways to do it but
the basics are that you use a detergent
for lysine or opening up the cells and
this allows you to get access for your
antibody later to get access to the new
nuclear fraction where your protein DNA
complexes are so the key to lysine
however you do choose to do it though is
that you really want to see this
morphological change so so shown here
are Peck 293 t-cells and on the left is
a crude nuclear purification before
lysine so you can see these nice with
the DAP T staining the nice nuclei now
with just three minutes of nuclear lysis
buffer and followed by 30 seconds of
sonication you can see on the right a
huge morphological change and that's
what's key no matter how you choose to
lyse is that you see this large
morphological change because if you do
not properly life your self your tip
experiment will not work as the antibody
cannot even get in to pull out that
protein DNA interactions also you'll
likely even upstream of that have
problems fragmenting your chromatin
you
so some tips from this step are some
that I've mentioned and some that I have
not yet are to spin the cells gently I
know I did not mention this yet but this
is something you want to make sure to do
because although you do want to life
yourself you don't want to prematurely
like them this is a step where if you
have to carefully like the cells and
spinning the cells gently is important
not to like them cross-linking is
time-sensitive excessive or inadequate
cross-linking can both lead to both
increased background or noise and also a
loss of DNA excessive or over
cross-linking can also lead to chromatin
that's difficult to fragment which will
reduce both your resolution and your IP
efficiency different types of cells
require different strengthen C's of cell
lysis so each cell type will the lysis
that may need to be optimized in some
cases just lysis buffer is adequate in
other cases you'll also want to add a
sonication step you want to keep buffers
cold and on ice during the whole time
and even when if you're taking cells
from the -80
you'll actually want to solve those cell
pellets on ice before you begin your
life so steps
covers our chromatin or our
cross-linking and lysa step and now
we're going to move on to chromatin
fragmentation and this is where you're
cutting up your chromatin to more
manageable sizes for your experiment you
can imagine you have this very long
piece of DNA or chromatin with all of
the proteins bound and cross-linked and
what you're interested altum Utley in
doing is finding out where your protein
of interest is on the genome and what's
important there is to fragment your
chromatin into manageable sizes so that
you can actually get a good picture of
where your protein is and is not on the
genome
so to do that you want to use some sort
of
imitation process whether its chemical
or enzymatic and two sets and the first
option is Earth
I'm sorry whether it's chemical or
mechanical the first option is
mechanical which is sonication and this
method is used for again fragmenting
you're chromatin and what you want to do
is as you'll see on the right this gel
at lower pulses you kind of see this
large smear chromatin and as you
increase the pulses in your sonication
you start to get more and more small
fragments of chromatin and that's
exactly what you want the ideal range is
between 200 and 800 base pairs but I'd
really say what you want is more like
200 to 300 base pair for fragmentation
is really ideal and especially if you're
looking to continue your experiment to
Tipsy core next-generation sequencing
because then you can really get a nice
footprint of where your protein is and
is not on the genome sonication needs to
be optimized for every cell line it's
something that's very important you
cannot rely on one method working for
across the board of cells it also needs
to be optimized for every sonicator so
once you find a sonicator that works you
also want to continue to use that
sonicator it's important to keep the
samples very cold because the heat can
actually reverse the cross-linking
cross-links at this stage and then
ultimately you'll have a very
inefficient experiment tip experiments
you need to prevent foaming when you're
sonicated ice foaming will actually
reduce the efficiency of the sonication
this method although very tried-and-true
it's also a very hands-on method to
fragment your chromatin and alternative
the option that has become I think more
popular is an enzymatic digestion and
specifically micro cockle nucleus or
eminates is used for this and let M&H
does is it basically chews up any
unprotected DNA which really means that
chews up most of the DNA that is not
associated with a nucleus film so I
would say this method is
particularly good if what you're
interested in is looking at histone and
histone modification a huge advantage to
it is that you can perform multiple
samples at the same time and shown here
on the left is a gel and what you'll see
is as you increase time with the M&H
digestion you start to see mono diet and
try nucleosomes and dye nucleosomes are
kind of that perfect size for what
you're for tip experiments but on the
right you may be able to see that again
cell line dependence is very important
to optimize cell line one you start to
see basically at the first time point
you can already see mono nucleosomal DNA
up here where it's really the second or
third time point in cell line two and
these samples were processed is exactly
the same time with the same enzyme so
every cell line needs to be optimized
additionally the enzyme can start to
lose activity due to age and/or storage
so with MMA s you almost need to
optimize for every experiment you do to
find that perfect time point to get that
mostly dye nucleus almost range eminates
although it does have a sequence
preference that's calling not as
important with chip but what is
important to know is it really is
chewing up all the DNA except for what's
associated with the nucleosome so it
really has a nucleus own preference i
would say in this case
just some tips from this section are
again some I mentioned some I'm not one
is that I know I did not mention is that
you really want to add protease and
phosphatase inhibitors to your dilution
buffers and why this is so important is
that you do want to maintain all of
those modifications on your proteins and
also maintain just the general integrity
of the protein so again if you're
interested in histone modification have
you want to make sure to maintain that
throughout fragmentation conditions need
to be optimized for each cell line
regardless of whether you're doing
chemical or mechanical fragmentation
always confirm that the fragmentation is
in the desired range because if your
fragmentation if it didn't work for
whatever reason then ultimately your
resolution is going to be very very
minimal as well as your chip efficiency
will be incredibly low for sonication
you want to keep samples cold and do
more pulses at lower power for the
enzymatic digestion or emanation
suggestion you want to you can optimize
time concentration and temperature to
all try to get that right amount for
getting mostly dye nucleosomal sized
fragments sonication nuclease digestion
can actually be used in combination for
particularly difficult cells to fragment
this is another stopping point although
I would say not as ideal because you
usually do take a little bit of a hit on
your protein and so you are going to
reduce your efficiency a little bit in
freezing at this step but it certainly
is a place where you can stop so now
we've covered chromatin fragmentation
and next we're going to move to immuno
precipitation they will say this is
going to be really the bulk of this
webinar immunoprecipitation is where you
are actually pulling out your protein of
interest with an antibody and the DNA
that it's associated with
picking the right antibody is key for
this and there's three main classes of
antibodies the first is a monoclonal and
one advantage to it is that it has
significant batch to batch consistency
particularly if you're using a
recombinant monoclonal antibody and
recombinant antibodies are becoming more
and more readily available one potential
disadvantage is that it recognizes a
single epitope so what that may mean for
your protein is if it's in several
confirmations in the cell your antibody
may only recognize one of the
confirmations so that's a disadvantage
to monocled on the advantage to
polyclonal is that it recognizes
multiple epitope so that potentially
you're going to get much more efficient
i pianned you're kind of getting a more
of a better or a better picture of your
where your protein is interacting in the
genome based on that the polyclonal
antibodies may recognize more
confirmations the unfortunate part of
polyclonal antibodies is they're very
limited resource and there's differences
from bleed to bleed in the animal and
then it's also dependent on that that
animal so that there are much more
limited resource than the monoclonal
thermo scientific offers an all ago
clonal antibody which is actually a pool
of our monoclonal recombinant antibodies
so I think that there could be some real
advantage to that as there's potential
fur to rec recognize multiple epitopes
as it's this pool of monoclonal
antibodies and we do have absolutely the
batch to batch consistency
now picking the right antibody is so
probably the utmost importance in your
tip experiment and question only becomes
is how do you do that and how do I know
my antibody is specific so the thing is
that it verified in tip what what does
that really mean you want to see that an
antibody is enriched in and expected
regions where you expect your protein to
be in the genome and depleted in other
regions where you do not expect your
protein to exist in the genome that's in
an ideal case sometimes you don't know
that much information about your protein
even a further league a further good
evidence although again may not be
possible
is that enrichment disappears or is
reduced in a knockout or knockdown cell
line in your tip experiment or there's a
change in enrichment upon salt treatment
this is another way to really feel
confident that your antibody is specific
for your protein of interest in chip I'm
going to show some data on there a
histone specific a state called snap tip
that epi cypher recently has launched
and also showed some data on chip
westerns which is another way to test
specificity and all these are really
focusing on chip specificity because
we're learning more and more than an
antibody that's specific in another
application that specificity does not
always translate to chip sometimes you
cannot find an antibody that's been
shown to work in chip and one idea is to
start looking for your own and testing
it and if that still isn't successful
affinity tagging is another alternative
the challenge of course is that your
first of all you have to add the tag to
your antibody to your protein of
interest and additionally beyond just
adding it then you you know have to
worry about whether your tag has any
effects on off off target effects on
your protein so I'm going to show now
some data both from our own website and
produced by thermo as well as from some
of our collaborators showing some
different ways we verified and
these in chip so the first example is
enrichment and depletion so SPF is
involved in DNA repair and is expected
to be located at promoter regions IgG on
this graph in yellow is the no antibody
control so this is just the beads
without the antibody and so you do not
expect to see any enrichment which we do
not see so that's good to just show
you're not just pulling down
nonspecifically on the beads now with
the antibody ex-bf indeed we're seeing a
large increase in enrichment in these
promoter regions and then in the gap th
gene or satellite DNA where we do not
expect to see xbf there is very little
enrichment so that's a nice showing of
suggestion that indeed this antibody is
specific another one shown here is h2 b
lysine 2007 which is associated with
actively transcribed genes and again in
this case you can't even see the IgG are
no antibody control because the full
enrichment is so high and you see a huge
increase in G active genes whereas a
very little enrichment in these less
active dream
when more example is h3k 36 tri methyl
this modification is known to associate
in gene bodies and in this data it shows
three different genes and you can see
the promoter has much less enrichment
compared to the gene bodies of gamma
actin al DOA and gas th so this again is
a nice demonstration of enrichment in
the expectant regions in this case the
gene bodies and much less in promoter
regions
now I mentioned cell treatment as
another way to test or even a kind of I
would say further specificity test and
this is shown here so crab which is a
transcription factor is activated by
phosphorylation and on the Western blot
on the left you can see that with the
addition of PMA which is the second lane
act PMA activates protein kinase is and
then and thus increases phosphorylation
MD you can see it on the Western blot
that there's an increase in the phospho
CREB in the second link now the chip on
the right shows something similar so in
blue at that IgG or no antibody control
for several different regions in the
genome and then you can see some
enrichment in a couple of the regions
when you are just the cells untreated so
that's the yellow so particularly the
second and third gene regions you see
some nice enrichment now when you add
that PMA that has activated the protein
kinase is an increased phosphorylation
you see a huge enrichment so that's
showing a change in a Richmond upon cell
treatment being a really nice
demonstration of specificity now we're
going to move to onto a histone specific
um validation method and this is called
snap chip and has recently been
developed by epi cipher it originally
comes from ice chip which is a method
developed in Alex Rustenburg lab at the
University of Chicago and the way this
method works is that they take
recombinant nucleosomes so they know
what modification is on it and there's a
DNA the DNA wrapped around it has a
barcode and this panel over combina
nucleosomes in this case is the k
metstat panel that includes mono diet
and try nucleosomes for h3k4 k9k 27k 36
in h4 k 20 are spiked in to your normal
chip workflow and then after processing
and you purify your DNA you can see not
only is your antibody pulling down the
modification you're interested in but
pulling down any of the other
modifications as well
and here's an example of data from one
of our antibodies so on the right is
h3k4 trimethylation can see the black
bar is the enrichment so this is how the
kind of efficiency of enrichment or tip
and it's really nice and high and then
what you want to see for a specific
antibody is that you want to see that
only it's really pulling down a ch3 in
this case h3k4 trimethylation at four
and very little of anything else so this
is exactly what you want to see for a
nice chip validated antibody and I
should mention that peptide arrays have
kind of been the standard for histone
modification specificity and although
they are fantastic for I think
identifying a large looking at a large
panel they are a denaturing application
and seem to be much more appropriate for
Western blot as a recent study in
molecular cell by Alex Rosenberg lab
Epis ifer and some of their other
collaborators have shown that peptide
array and snap tip or in this case ice
tip efficiencies specificities do not
correlate so an antibody that might look
great by peptide array that does not
mean it looks great for specificity in
chip and that's why I think this method
is so important for these histone
modifications so back to the data on
this slide is that I was going to say
that the ones that are star we've shown
similarly to this h3k4 that it's really
a clear clean panel where it's only
pulling down the end of the target of
interest and less than 20 percent cross
reactivity with anything else in the
target the ones in blue shaded boxes in
the panel we still have not yet
identified a great antibody in our
portfolio for tip and we're still that's
very much an ongoing process and
hopefully we will have some of those
very soon and there's a couple that are
not star but they're not shaded out and
those are ones where we're still trying
to fight we have something but it's not
absolutely ideal there might be a little
bit higher than
20% cross-reactivity and at least one
modification now the question is as I
mentioned peptide array and ice chip or
snap tip specificity do not seem to
correlate for histone modifications but
how important is the specificity and the
answer is it's very important so it's a
little bit of a complicated slide and
this actually comes from data from that
molecular cell paper I just mentioned so
you can see the reference at the bottom
and what they found is again in the
circle right at the top there's this ice
chip specificity so for ma h3k4
monomethylation you can see that then
that's agreed both antibodies they
looked at by chip seek have ice chip
specificity of over 90 percent and their
chip seat tracks are very similar the
same with the dimethyl where the
specificity is over 90 percent and they
have very similar chip seat taxes and I
should mention that on the right those
numbers in black are actually from our
catalog numbers for these antibodies are
the thermo Fisher antibodies used in
this study now when we get to red things
fall apart unfortunately so this is the
h3k4 trimethylation ii and they do have
very similar tips ich tracks but when
you look at the bottom two red ones that
are more hovering around ninety percent
specificity they have significantly
different tips ich tracks than there are
counter parts above and what those extra
Peaks in the top two red ones of h3k4
trimethylation is the dimethyl so this
is really skewing your data where when
you think this is where h3k4
trimethylation
essential for understanding your chip it
particularly for going on to chip seek
but even a chip qpcr your data could be
confused without this on specificity
now this is a very histone specific
technique so we're also interested in
plenty of antibodies or targets that are
not histones the chip Western is a good
way to also look at specificity this is
another method that kind of can be
incorporated into your normal chip
workflow in this case you cross-linked
your you know you cross-linked yourself
like the cell's fragment the chromatin
as you've done before and do your immuno
precipitation but instead of then going
on to purify the DNA or at least taking
a fraction of this immunoprecipitation
you examined not just the DNA but the
protein so you boil the protein off the
beads and then you can do a western blot
with the same or different antibody to
the target used for kit and see am i
pulling down my protein of interest I'm
going to show a couple examples of that
the first being lemons and the reason
lemons are hard is that they provide the
nuclear structural organization but
they're also all over the place so it's
challenging to determine antibody
specificity as it's hard to identify
regions of depletion so on the left is
lemon AC and what you'll see in the
first Lane is your input so this is what
you're putting into your immuno
precipitation the second Lane is just a
GG so no antibody and then the third
Lane is on the actual IP and they are
again so in the input you would expect
to see your protein as well as in the
lane 3 your IP it's similar story on the
right and this is looking at lamin b1
and this actually looks at and about two
antibodies from other suppliers in lanes
one and four into thermo scientific
antibodies in lanes 2 and 3 and all four
antibodies are showing that they are
indeed pulling down lamin b1 suggesting
that this is that your tip experiment is
working and it's pulling down your
protein of interest
another example this is for an RNA
binding protein so probably would be
more appropriate to call it a risk
western and this is for RNA pol 2 on the
left and BL a VL 1 on the right which
binds and stabilizes mRNA and in this
case I recommend focusing on lanes 2 & 4
so lean 2 is the pulldown of IgG some no
antibody and in both cases or in all
cases you would expect to see no protein
as you're not you are not actually
adding antibody and and indeed that's
the case now Lane 4 is where you do your
actual IP and in both cases you see
protein and in some cases you'll
actually see it enriched over your
inputs which are in lanes 1 & 3 one
final example of tip Western actually
includes
peptide competition which is an even
kind of additional specificity test so
in this case again you have your your
input Lane and then your IgG or no
antibody so um and then you add in
either no blocking peptide or blocking
peptide so this is for antibody h3k 36m
III which i told you some data earlier
that is associated with gene bodies and
we've also validated this antibody and
snap chip and looks really nice this
case you've ads are at no peptide or a
k36 mono die or try peptides and in the
case of no peptide or mono or die
peptide you see h3k 36m III as labeled
and then that band disappears in that
last Lane where the k36 tripeptide has
been added and further if you look at
the bottom of the Dell you actually see
that pop ID light up so these are just
all ways of looking at your antibody
specificity and any is my antibody
really pulling down what I think it is
and then in some cases also not only is
it pulling down what I think it is but
ensuring it's not pulling down what you
do not want it to
now another thing you may need to do is
actually look at your antibody
concentration so once you've identified
a good antibody it might require some
tie tering of your antibody to find the
ideal amount in this top example here is
for an h3k27 trimethylation
you can see as you increase from left to
right the amount of antibody you also
increase the percent enrichment this
however is not always the case that more
is better the next two examples were
provided kindly by FD cyber in the
middle example this is for h3k9 dimethyl
antibody and this time the increasing
goes from right to left and indeed if
you look at focus on that black bar you
see an increase in enrichment as you
increase the antibody so that looks
great and you really see about similar
or even sometimes an increase in
specificity which is really nice because
this is not just looking at h3k9
dimethyl pull down but also looking at
h3k9 mono try and just a ch3 so this
looks really nice but you can always
count on that because in the bottom
example again it goes from right to left
on increase in antibody you do see an
increase in the efficiency as you focus
on that black bar but for this one it's
an h3k4 trimethylation and as you
increase the antibody you also start to
see an increase in the pulling down of
h3k4 dimethyl which is not what you want
so although there's an increase in an
inefficiency of pulldown you're also
decreasing your specificity so the
antibody concentration can definitely be
a touchy thing usually you'll incubate
your arm lysate with your um antibody
overnight and then in the morning add
beads there's two types of beads you can
use magnetic or address other speeds
certainly have the advantage of higher
binding capacity but generally speaking
magnetic beads are a little bit easier
to use but it's really about what your
comfort level isn't which ones you have
a preference for in most cases
you do need to select the right binding
protein for the IgG antibody cell class
in most cases protein a/g is a great
choice but it is something you want to
be aware of with your antibody making
sure that that is the appropriate choice
you just want to ensure your beads never
dry out and I would recommend for
texting very lightly to resuspend so you
get a nice slurry before you add them
next step after bead incubation is
washing the beads and this is a bit of a
tedious step a very very important step
so I highly recommend being very patient
with your washings
you go from low to salt high walk low to
salt high salt washes and you want to be
careful with how the stringency so in
some cases when you have these really
strong interactions you can really go
quite high in your salt washes to really
wash away the nonspecific or is in other
cases you might want to go a little bit
lower on the salt particularly if you
did not cross link yourself then you'll
do a lithium chloride wash and that
reduces the sodium and also switches the
salt which can remove other nonspecific
binding you'll want to do a tea you wash
so that you guys it kind of neutralized
and ready for the next stages of DNA
purification so some tips from this
section are picking the right antibody
for tips is essential and that probably
would be the biggest take-home message
I'd like you to take on this whole
webinar validated and chip or IP
antibodies is obviously preferable and
really being able to show specificity
and specifically if you want to show
that specificity for tip and not all
application specificities are
transferable sometimes however you're
interested in something where there is
not a clear tip antibody out there
I see an if' are certainly good
indicators that the antibody is a good
candidate for tip but that absolutely
needs to be tested you do always want to
add a new antibody control to
distinguish chip signal from background
antibody titrations might be necessary
for identifying the best signal-to-noise
ratio I would generally say to my
programs is a good starting point or
what your the data product sheet for
your antibody
commenced is also very good starting
point watching tendency also may need to
be optimized for your particular chip
reaction in your particular antibody so
now we've covered the muta precipitation
step and the next step will be much
quicker which is preparation of DNA and
this is where you're purifying your DNA
so you can ultimately see where your
protein is associated I'm so for DNA
preparation you aleut the chromatin from
the antibody and then reverse the
cross-links as well as degrade the
protein with proteinase k RNA street to
remove all the RNA from your sample and
then purify the DNA what either by a
female chloroform extraction and or a
PCR clean up okay
and that's really how you prepare your
DNA and then you this is also another
stopping point where your DNA can be
stored at minus 24 as long as you please
so that's the preparation of DNA and now
we get to the quantitation of DNA so
this is where you're figuring out how
much is enriched how much D is enriched
at any specific low side you're
interested in
you
so the quantitation of DNA you need to
identify regions to examine so what
regions are you interested in do no
regions where you expect you're in above
your protein to be and not be in the
genome and you want to design and test
primers for those regions and I would
highly recommend actually designing at
least a couple primer sets for each
region its primer design and testing can
be a little bit of a hit or miss
experiment in itself then you'll do two
PCR to actually amplify those regions
and analyze that data now this might be
your stopping point this might be your
you know what regions you're interested
in and you do that might test them or
you may now prepare your DNA for on
next-generation sequencing our first tip
seek so identifying the regions to
examine so if you're interested in the
where this blue ball protein is you
would identify a couple regions and
design primers to amplify these regions
to see is my protein there or has has my
chip pulled down this reagent of DNA and
how much of it you'll also want to a
design at least a region it's not a
couple where you do not expect your
protein because what you want to ensure
is that your you haven't just kind of
pulled down generally all of chromatin
then you're amplifying everything after
you've identified those regions you'll
design primers amplification regions
should usually be between 100 and 250
base pairs I would err on kind of a goal
of around 150 base pairs primers should
ideally be 18 to 25 base pairs with a 40
to 60% GC content if possible I can that
can be a hard thing sometimes do I get
that depending on the region you're
looking for
the TM should be between 50 and 65
degrees definitely no higher than 65 and
again this is where I had air toward
kind of 55% 55 degrees being being a
goal you want to see a single dominant
peak when you look at your melting curve
and I've just shown two examples on
there for the year where on the left is
the good melting curve and you see this
nice strong one peak compared to on the
right the bad melting curve where
there's just lots of peaks and then on
the next I'm going to stress more about
this but you want to look at your primer
efficiency which should be between 90
and 105 degrees if you're in particular
qPCR but you may do this calculation for
you
but this is showing you how to figure
out primer efficiency and also just how
to set it up so you're going to want to
take either your input from your chip
reaction or you can just use some
genomic DNA in the freezer and do a qPCR
where you diluted the sample i've sever
logs and then that's going to be graphed
verses on the CT and what the CT is is
it's the value or the cycle where your
fluorescence signals in your to PCR
reaches a threshold above background and
so that's kind of the raw data that
you're qpcr provides when that's graphed
you'll get a slope and you use that for
this equation at the bottom four percent
efficiency and here's again two examples
on the left is the good timer efficiency
this is a 100 percent and then on the
right and you can just see from the data
it does not look nice all those blue
dots are nowhere near the line but this
is a bad primer efficiency at a hundred
and seventy percent now it might seem
odd how it's actually more efficient but
what that means is it's actually
amplifying not just the region you're
interested in but probably other regions
in the genome
now the next slide I'm going to show you
is a bit complicated but provides the
calculations for what to do with the
data from your qPCR in some cases your
machine might do this for you but I
think it's really important to
understand what the analysis is so
there's two ways to graph your tip data
the first graph which is shown already
here on the left is the fold enrichment
which just looks at the signal over the
background or no antibody and the
equations are just above the graph so
your delta CT gives the signal minus the
background and so what you'll see is you
take your IP signal so this is the again
that cycle threshold and then you - it
from your IgG or your no antibody
control and that gives you the Delta CT
and you take this Delta CT and again the
equation is right above the graph to
figure out the fold enrichment and so
again this gives you how much is
enriched above background in your
experiment now an alternative
calculation is to look at the percentage
of inputs and what that this calculation
represents is the amount of DNA pulled
down relative to the starting material
or input so in this case first you need
to adjust the inputs so in general your
input your not your I mean of course
you're not taking 100% as your input as
a sample because then you would have
nothing to IP so you often take 1% or so
of your input which is what's done in
this example and you need to adjust this
because 1% was used only 1% was used for
tip so you take a dilution factor is a
hundred and the blog base set of two of
a hundred is six point six five so
that's just to understand where that -
six six five comes from so you take your
input and then minus it by six point six
five to get your adjusted inputs then
from there you can calculate
your % IP and again the formulas are
just above the bar graph and here you
take your adjusted input
and minus it by the IP to get your
percent input so again these are just
two different ways to look at your data
and I know this is a little bit of a
beast of a slide but it's just to
understand how those calculations
particularly pure qpcr machine spits
them out just having a little background
to how music actually are calculated now
that may have been your stopping point
you may have looked at a number of
regions that you're interested in and
you figured out what you want to know
about your protein but you may already
have known this or you may have decided
you know what I not want to know much
more about what's going on in the whole
genome with my protein of interest and
here's where you'd move to NGS and I'm
really not going to talk about NGS but
just wanted to show you that the chip
workflow here shown on the left and then
on the right you just kind of that
workflow can go right into preparing
libraries for Tipsy so you're already
well on your way to a tip seek
experiment if you are planning right
from the beginning of doing the chip
seek experiment I still very much would
suggest testing a few regions by qPCR to
ensure that your tip experiment is good
before you invest the time and money in
sequencing so a few steps from this
section primers need to be assessed by
their melting curves and their
efficiencies on input or genomic DNA a
few important controls that I did not
mention for qpcr is you want to have a
no antibody and I mean I'm sorry a no
DNA and then no reverse transcriptase
control just to make sure all your
reagents are nice and clean and there's
no contamination as that would skew your
data and I've already mentioned you
always want to perform a few Q PCR
reactions even if your intention is to
move to NGS to ensure your tip is a
quality experiment that you'd like to
move to NGS so some conclusions from
this whole webinar are determining the
goal for your experiment is key before
beginning to design the best experiment
things to determine before you start tip
are the conditions you want to fragment
your chromatin identifying antibodies
you want to use that you feel confident
or good
or how you're going to test that they're
good in specific because that's
sometimes what's necessary and you also
I would recommend actually having your Q
PCR primers already ready to go and have
been designed and confirming their
efficiencies are good before you get too
far in your chip experiments as you've
seen throughout there's many steps and
chip and there's many places that need
optimization for whatever your
experiment requires whether it's out do
to the cell line or the type of target
there's lots of places that require our
optimization and anywhere along the way
that you can check to see if it's
working I highly recommend that so
things like checking to confirm that
your fragmentation is good and checking
to confirm your life is good in checking
that your qPCR primers are good are
always to just ensure along the way that
you're getting the best experiment and
with that I'd like to thank a number of
my colleagues at Thermo Fisher
Scientific who helped put this webinar
together as well as providing data for
this webinar additionally I had several
collaborators kindly give me data to
include in this webinar and I thank them
very much for that and lastly I think
epi cipher who shared um not only data
provided from their own work but also
have been great collaborators along the
way
and with that I thank you and I will
take questions
Thank You dr. small for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is chip
western seem to show that the antibody
is pulling down the protein of interest
but how does it show specificities
that's a great point because what I
showed you is that you can see that your
protein is being pulled down but you
have no idea what else is being pulled
down and the case of the histone
modification it gave a little bit more
information because the peptide
competition was at it so that you could
see then that it was competed off only
when the tri methyl peptide was at it
but you're absolutely correct that that
that doesn't fully show specificity so
things I would recommend doing our upon
do staining of your membrane or silver
staining of your gel and what you would
expect to see is mostly just your
protein you may see some other proteins
especially if your protein you know is
in a complex but that's going to add
another layer of specificity by being
able to just see a pretty clean gel or
membrane where you're not seeing that
protein
now how do I to excuse me now how do I
identify where the nonspecific binding
is coming from and therefore how to
troubleshoot it well yeah that's a hard
question because probably saw throughout
there's many reasons so the first thing
is to confirm that your antibody is
really specific and if you if you're
confident that your antibody is specific
then that it's not coming directly from
your antibody then there are definitely
things you can do unfortunately if
you're not confident your antibody
specific or you find your antibodies not
specific then you just need to start
over but if you feel that your antibody
is good one place to look at is
chromatin fragmentation if you want to
make sure again that you're on that kind
of 200 400 maybe a little above base
pairs because a lack of good chromatin
fragmentation you basically not only is
your efficiency of pull down lower but
you really kind of increase how much you
can amplifying your DNA of where the
protein is so that footprint becomes
much bigger and then you're not getting
that same nice resolution so it might be
it might be that's not pulling down
something nonspecific that it but that
it's more that you're only seeing your
you're seeing kind of these large
fragments that you're amplifying another
thing would be I mean I'd highly
recommend also using methanol free
formaldehyde because um methanol
contamination can cause problems with
fragmentation another thing that can
cause problems with fragmentation is
over cross-linking so if you've
cross-linked for too long it makes it
really hard for fragmentation to occur
so all of those kind of things will make
it look like maybe more nonspecific
binding
additionally for nonspecific binding you
can alter your washing conditions
because that can lead to other problems
um or that you haven't washed off all of
the nonspecific but yeah it's a hard
question because there's just a lot of
places where nonspecific
can take place but I say fragmentation
and washing are some of the big ones if
you if you're confident your antibody is
specific
we've gotten so many good questions
saved but it looks like we only have
time for one more so our next question
and final question will be if my
antibody works in the chip qpcr will it
work and chip seek if your antibody is
really specific but the efficiency is
low sometimes that's okay particularly
for just doing tip QP crm it's kind of
at these regions that you really know
are going to be enriched but what
happens sometimes is in that case where
it's really enriched in certain regions
because that's kind of where all the
protein is hanging out then you find
that when you do tip seek the signals
like the noise is really high compared
to signal so I would say mostly yes your
tip um if an antibody works for tips
qpcr it should work for tip seek but the
cases where it becomes more questionable
as when your tip efficiency is low and I
would say kind of like hovering around
you know one two percent I start to get
a little more concern that it might not
work as well and definitely if it's
anything less than you know 1% I'd be
very nervous doing to speak with that
and then I would lastly say probably
ideally you wanted probably five percent
or higher it's kind of you're in a much
more safe zone and much more likely to
have successful tips Peaks
Thank You dr. small do you have any
final comments for our audience um I
mean I would just say you know there's
lots of text along the way so really try
to slow down and try to optimize every
step where you can and the other thing
would be choosing the right antibody and
really testing its specificity as
stringently as you can for ensuring a
successful chip experiment and good luck
thank you again dr. small for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank laberd's and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational
webcasts before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on-demand or
April of 2019 Leopards will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live of it until next time
goodbye